all right Chelsea Chelsea oh where you
from merging where'd you grow up next to
me and how is your chocolate group of
both your parents yeah my childhood was
rough house that I grew up in the Bronx
and my parents were like in the drug
scene I think selling drugs and I got I
got a raise in the Trap House
I'm sorry I think I kind of got raised
in like a trap I was kind of widows like
a bunch of them has two teats around all
the time and
and they got they diagnose 14 and then
that's I'm traveling
my mom my mom got shot and my dad grew
up and car do they look like - it so
separate accidents both when you were 14
yeah but I have a twin sister that's a
trans man and to the Trevor and I were
through you know me and and I liked that
I was a black [ __ ] okay any other
craziness in your childhood
yeah la la huh I had some issues with
sex oscillations when I'll be 13 eyes on
prostitution and then 11 - very well
I'll either pass I pass you did and did
drugs for the first time
oh you did my 13 mm-hmm yeah cuz I watch
my mom doing it and then I saw I thought
it would be okay and then I tried it and
then Isaac up to the minute and then and
that's the drugs and then you know it
lets you me like doing some dumb stuff
like trying to steal from stores or just
getting in trouble and rebelling
otherwise that nothing really ever
happened
positive for everything you're a foster
home
I think ashrams in group homes stuff
your parents passed away yeah I just
prepare what's really I really repented
and then I ran away from the group home
and I started hitchhiking with my
ex-boyfriend and you know we hitchhiked
it
our first with my first date I was 14
and I got us a ride out here to thank
her name and then from then remained the
guy wanted us to ride with him September
you know I don't really remember
so you've been all over the country mmm
you been all over the country
yeah then everything on the states and I
went to Alaska twice and I didn't do
half of Mexico and like it's the whole
country of Canada oh really
yeah I wrote my dreams in hitchhike
pretty much all right sir yeah it was
really kind of hard once I stopped
writing I got stuck here it was kind of
hard to communicate with with the human
race again cuz I said I had a no three
animals are afraid to intervene stuff
and communicating with them but it does
a lot different you know
so I kind of forgot how to cope with
other people so what is your drug ha
right now my Begich weighs what is it is
crack it always load of crap but I don't
do crack anymore
you know I mean and right now I'm trying
to thinking first on crystal meth like
now at the very moment rate exactly
right now but yeah I do once in a while
those batons all been on my back for
like three days just riding and not
sleeping
Kristen oh um I don't think is funny
because well I have manic stages to that
I can't sleep for like a week at a time
or something but Matt's had a lot to do
with it but um I just turned 29 29
yesterday and I can say I still feel
like like an endurance wise or a
physical eyes I definitely got the
teenagers though yeah like I don't feel
like English and since I was like 15 in
June yeah that works out and you said
you have a 10 now oh really
oh I don't I had I had a 10 min tenth
and then um without myself in there like
my sleeping bag and had a bed in there
and a stove and everything I needed in
there and somebody burnt my stuff down
what happens here long yeah they burnt
it to the ground and then the next day
they wanted to try to apologize like I'm
sorry we didn't know this is that we
thought this was three hours I like that
maybe just I found out whose it was
before you burned it down
and woody are you doing for money now
it's crown G on the street looking for
change or you know I come up a bag for
that I didn't carve eh I tried my stuff
here in deer or I come up on things on
the street there's in the garbage and I
trade but it never leave money more like
stuff I need ya dear you ever date guys
for Mike and I have yeah that's not I
don't anymore I mean I haven't done that
in like since I was 25 but and I don't
really have any passion for idea do you
ever talk to your brother huh
you ever talk to your brother no I don't
talk to I knew my family I was really
like the black sheep like I when I left
something like gods last time I talked
to him I am do you have any friends you
have a lot of friends were they around
not like right here but like the toughts
from Wall Street I have friends over
there I have I still have friends in New
York actually
oh no I mean it's kind of hard to say to
our friends because I make friends have
Rosa go I'm not a hard person to get
along with I mean I've had a couple
friends over actually homophobia but
there for some reason they just accepted
me and you know if everybody else was
like guy or whatever they would you
would be like Oh [ __ ] is I forgot that
and then but if this person I go is a
professional no do you think you'll be
living like this for the rest of your
life no this isn't something I wanna be
doing because I'm kind of already I'm
kind of already like tied up with
because California is probably the worst
had ever been like I've been to all
these places then nothing have really
bad happen except for here like I
thought my first charge in California
your birth mother's birth dad like Jojo
should know huh what was that for
um I tried to steal two phones out of
Target and it didn't really work out and
then I didn't really know that last
prevention was because we don't Lee have
that back home so they were trying to
disguise themselves in there and the one
in the middle was talking about a
baguette and something but the way they
were walking I put mean I thought I gave
me attack pair those were high and kind
of kinda nervous and scared
I got a punch guy in the face I guess
and I went to jail and because he didn't
press charges I got off that and then
they dropped my robbery charge down to a
misdemeanor
I mean a grand theft on person and then
I did five months in jail for there a
month later i absconded probation and
then I did several moments good as hours
trying to saw somebody had a handbag on
that and McDonald like Latin in high wit
and I went to jail for several months
and then when I got how I was doing gave
and then you know I caught up with one
when I was friends and then I sort of
having ties to time again and then they
fell to tell me that they had HIV
Tennyson I realized I caught it I
realized that I had HIV and my best
myself somebody who's supposed to be my
best friend gave it to me and they
couldn't even tell me they have it
younger yeah and then I went to a lot in
LA actually I found probably and I went
through some [ __ ]
but I don't think I haven't been through
as much it is that I think I've been to
put it over here no like it even when I
was a kid I grew up rough when I mean
not like this yeah thanks
I never imagined $29 bit you know
sitting in California how much in Havana
Jovie nothing
I think the homeless communities on the
west coast are a little more extreme
than they are
yeah elsewhere and um out here is kind
of hard because me being white and trans
is a little bit harder because the a lot
of the like a big population is black or
Spanish so for some reason I feel like
because a lot of people a lot of people
that I hang around they say is because
when I skin color Y or whatever and icon
that and picking it up that maybe that's
true
maybe it's not you know but it's like
I've had boyfriend's here and they work
out really and you know nothing has
really worked out for me in particular I
or I do have a lot of friend stuff um
and you know I also I've cut down a lot
bygones whenever you're using what huh
you're using less
yeah a lot less than I was because I was
looking like to a boss
within just a morning time you know and
that would be every day I was pumped
like that almost 20 bars every morning
and then I was so smug all day and now
I'm like smoking like $20 for it which
is which is a tremendous amount of
change
you know and I'm trying to you know day
day by day I try to sit around and make
money or make some changes again some
cigarettes or
I I know it's not cute to do or it's not
the best thing to do but it's like a
survival tactic like sometimes I boost
from the store like I found hungry like
if I intentionally desperately need
something from the store and I don't
have money for I'll go try to do it and
sometimes it doesn't work out so I was
late at 8 chordates and the next six
months yeah yeah I had got caught
stealing and cut another another
citation or something but most of this
happens only for tough I desperately
needed you know but and it says one
thing every day Sunday yeah alright
thank you so much for talking to me
mm-hmm and good luck with with
everything
you